so there was a political context around
this trial politics shouldn't have
any effect on any trial again that's
antithetical to what justice
is but they did intrude at every level
of this case
we'll tell you how after the verdict joe
biden declared that systemic racism is a
stain on this country's soul
a jury in minnesota
found former minneapolis police officer
derrick chauvin
guilty on all counts in the murder
of george floyd last may
it was a murder in the full light of day
and it ripped the blinders off for the
whole world to see
the systemic racism the vice president
just referred to
there were systemic racisms as a stain
on our nation's soul
the knee on the neck of justice for
black americans
enough enough of this senseless killings
today today's verdict
is a step forward
systemic racism a term that neither joe
biden or anyone else
who uses it has ever defined with any
precision whatsoever
but more striking is biden's posture
you'd think he'd be excited by this
just this morning as the jury was still
deliberating the president of the united
states said
he was praying for a guilty verdict
i'm praying the verdict is the right
verdict which is i think it's
overwhelming in my view
i wouldn't say that but see the jury was
sequestered now
not hear me say that
when was the last time a sitting
president weighed in on a jury decision
before it was made answer never
the white house was asked about this
just a few hours later and pretended
that joe biden hadn't actually said
what he actually said you're not able to
clarify what is overwhelming the
evidence
the case presented by the prosecution
we're not going to get ahead of the
outcome
i expect when there is a verdict he will
have more to say
the president has talked about the
importance of an independent
judiciary why is it appropriate for him
to weigh in on the verdict
even though the jury i wouldn't think
i don't think he would see it as
weighing in on the verdict he was
conveying what many people are feeling
across the country
yeah he was just conveying what many
people were feeling he wasn't weighing
in as the single most powerful man
in the world on a jury verdict that
hadn't been reached yet he didn't say
what you saw him say if that sounds like
a familiar defense it's exactly what
maxine waters and her defenders
throughout washington are using today
after waters threatened the jury with
violence if it didn't find a guilty
verdict
we've got to not only stay in the street
but we've got to fight for justice
but i am very hopeful and i hope
that we're going to get a verdict
that is a guilty guilty guilty i don't
know whether it's in the first degree
but as far as i'm concerned as folks
well we got to stay on the street uh and
we've got to get more
active we've got to get more
confrontational
we've got to make sure that they they
know that we need business
so there's a reason police were all over
the streets and cities across the
country last night and it's that
it's the threat of violence and maxine
waters threatened violence before the
jury had even begun to consider the
facts of the case
that's so far over the line that we read
some democrats were shocked by it and
yet
no one condemned it that includes the
president and includes the most powerful
people in the democratic party the
speaker of the house nancy pelosi steny
hoyer of maryland
they came out in support of maxine
waters
and then state media literally state
media public broadcasting system
came out today with an explanation at
the white house press briefing watch
this propagandist explain what maxine
waters
really meant um representative waters as
you said clarified she said
my actual words don't matter i wonder
why the white house isn't also coming to
the defense of representative waters
given
the fact that she's now facing an
onslaught of attacks especially but i
would say republicans i wonder why the
white house isn't saying
we we back what she said about being
confrontational she was obviously not
threatening violence there are civil
rights leaders they're saying that's
what
that's what civil rights is to be
confrontational to be active
well she could she also clarified her
own remarks amish and i think that's the
most powerful piece to point to
that lady works for you she literally
works for
public television and there she is
ardently flacking
for lunatic maxine waters at the white
house press briefing oh it's all normal
don't worry it's always been this way it
hasn't always been this way
and our leaders haven't always talked
like they're seized by religious fervor
here was the speaker of the house today
thanking george floyd because he died in
order to make the democratic party more
powerful for his sacrifice she said
watch this
thank you george floyd for sacrificing
your life for justice
because of you and because of
thousands millions of people around the
world who came out
for justice your name will always be
synonymous
with justice unless we can change the
law
this will be an episode we changed the
law
we're going down a different path all
together
so the guy dies on the sidewalk and here
this lady comes out and politicizes it
so completely that he becomes sort of
democratic party saint thank you for
your sacrifice this is grotesque it's a
cult
obviously